let's start today with some meaty policy
analysis when it comes to taxing the
rich please don't tune out no no no
don't click away no in all seriousness
this morning I watched a little bit of
our friend Sam Cedar's appearance on the
Patrick Bet David show a program I did a
month or six weeks ago or so and one of
the topics that came up with them was
about what should tax rates be and
taxing the rich and Sam says yes and
Patrick says no and okay I don't want in
this segment to delve into the should we
or shouldn't we or the morals of the
ethics what I simply want to address
here is if we wanted to tax the ultra
wealthy more
how would we do it effectively and what
I mean by effectively is it's very easy
to say raise the top income tax rate but
then you realize wait a second a lot of
the ultra wealthy aren't earning income
in wages subject to that rate so that's
not really going to help and in the
background of all of this is the news
that Democratic senators as HuffPost
reports are urging the Biden
Administration to go after what they
call ultra wealthy tax Dodgers most of
this is specifically related to using
trusts and other Financial Vehicles when
it comes to inheritance when it comes to
inheritance and what we might call a
state tax or some like to call it the
death tax so what I want to do in this
segment just to provide a little bit of
food for thought is give a bunch of
different changes that could be made to
the tax code
that would help tax the ultra wealthy
now I know that many of you are going to
write to me and you're going to say but
David that method wouldn't work because
of this reason and this other method
wouldn't work because of that other
reason this is very much like when we
look at an issue like gun violence no
one policy would cover all mass
shootings and prevent every single one
when we talk about uh waiting periods
mandatory liability insurance limiting
certain Firearms only to those over age
25 requiring re-licensing and more
extensive training right we have this
list that I've put together of 10 to 12
different items that could be put in
place
no single one would prevent every mass
shooting and in a country of 330 million
people 340 million people no matter what
you do there might still be some mass
shootings but the point is what's the
lowest hanging fruit what can we do to
in the case of the tax element
collect more from the ultra wealthy so
here's the list and I'll tell you how
they would work and their limits and
again no there's no Silver Bullet here
so okay should we raise the top marginal
income tax rate yeah we probably should
saying that at I don't remember where it
is right now 550 000 or so dollars a
year you hit the top tax rate of 37
percent and from there up there's no
more brackets and no higher marginal tax
rates that's probably too too low there
should probably be some more brackets
with some higher rates but that won't
get us all of that Ultra Rich tax
revenue that we might be seeking because
a lot of the ultra wealthy aren't
earning money via wages they're also
able to reduce taxes through deductions
and tax credits Etc okay so one tool is
you raise the top marginal tax rate it's
not going to do everything you want it
to do secondly you can look at imposing
a wealth tax on certain Assets Now that
is going to it's quite difficult to
implement I'm honestly not even
completely sure that it would pass all
legal muster but it's an idea that's
been proposed you impose a wealth tax to
try to get it taxation of assets rather
than just income now what are the
problems well what do you do about
illiquid assets do you tax the value of
Fine Art who determines what the Fine
Art is worth you probably have to
exclude an asset like Fine Art and so
what this leads to is that those who
hold valuable assets can either move
assets to countries with no wealth taxes
invest in assets that are difficult to
value or would be Exempted like artwork
or rare Collectibles okay but it might
do something and to be clear I'm not
necessarily advocating for every single
one of these policies I'm telling you
what is on the what is in the toolbox so
to speak number three there are tax
loopholes that could be closed one such
loophole is the so-called carried
interest loophole however
there would be some ultra wealthy folks
who will find ways to get around that
either moving the types of assets that
would have previously benefited benefit
benefited from the carried interest
loophole into non-taxable assets like
municipal bonds not totally realistic
for the hedge fund managers that that
would be targeted at admittedly looking
at changing business structure moving
certain assets offshore lobbying for a
new different loophole the next time
there's a friendly Administration so is
it a Panacea no but is it a tool
absolutely number four
increasing IRS funding to do more audits
of the ultra wealthy now there are some
people in that income bracket that are
doing everything right it's not like
with all of these folks if they were
audited the government would find that
they have underpaid their taxes so for
those who are legally and correctly
avoiding taxes auditing them isn't going
to make a difference but we know that
there is significant underpayment in
that group and having a more well-funded
IRS not with agents with guns Just audit
agents to do audits would certainly uh
claw back some of that Revenue that
should have been paid a financial
transaction tax if you put in place a
financial transaction tax the ultra
wealthy who might not earn any income
and pay very little as far as income
taxes go
but are involved in financial
transactions they would have to pay a
tax on those transactions and as with
anything else they could look at
stopping the financial transactions in
order to not generate those taxable
events moving assets offshore to
countries that don't have such attacks
or investing in assets not subjected to
that tax certainly could do it but it is
another tool
raising capital gains if you are worried
about not collecting tax revenue from
the ultra wealthy because they are
earning money that is subject to capital
gains rather than income tax you could
raise the tax on capital gains it's not
a silver bullet you could avoid that tax
as an ultra-rich person by waiting to
take any gains or through other
mechanisms an alternative minimum tax
Alternative Minimum Tax says listen if
this is your income before deductions no
matter how many deductions you take
there is a minimum level of tax that you
have to pay you can't deduct and credit
your way all the way down below some
certain amount that's a good idea High
earners might still be able to reduce
their taxable income significantly
through the tools that do remain
available but it's an it's a tool the
Alternative Minimum Tax you could look
at increasing corporate taxes that is a
great idea that being said you have to
remember that that only applies to
certain types of Corporations s
corporations and LLCs and sole
proprietorships those are what are
called pass-through type entities and
those are governed by the personal
income tax rate not by the corporate tax
rate but certainly it would make a
difference so these are all tools that
are available every single one
is at risk of being circumvented at
least partially depending on what tax
methods and uh strategies you use but
taken together much like doing 10 or 12
different things about gun safety it
would have a significant impact in its
totality now this is a separate issue
from as I discussed on the Patrick Bet
David show I'm not immediately looking
to just raise all sorts of taxes what I
think is the really the lowest hanging
fruit is number one what are we getting
for the taxes we already pay what are
the taxes being used for and secondly
getting actually closer to the tax rates
that are in place simply by focusing on
deductions credits and loopholes but
that's a subject subject for a different
day last item about this any time that
there's a tax proposal
and you hear oh this would raise 10
billion or whatever the case may be it's
really important to understand whether
that estimate of this would generate 10
billion dollars in tax revenue is it
based on a dynamic scoring system and
what I mean by that is it's very easy to
say based on the way people filed their
taxes last year if we put in place this
new tax it would generate 10 billion
dollars what needs to be taken into
account is that last year if this tax
had been in place
people might have used the different tax
strategy in response to the fact that
that tax was put in place so whenever we
examine this type of proposal of any
kind when it comes to taxes you want to
dynamically score what it would do by
accounting for how people's behavior
might change send me your thoughts is
this interesting to people let me know